before we get into the topic of weak
acid equilibria let's look at a strong
acid first
so let's say that h a is a strong acid
and reacts with water to produce the
hydronium ion and a minus the conjugate
base 2 2ha
technically the reaction comes to an
equilibrium however the equilibrium
favors the product so much that we don't
draw an equilibrium arrow we simply draw
an arrow going to the right indicating
at equilibrium we have essentially all
h3o plus and a minus and no ha so we
assume that a strong acid ionizes 100
percent in solution and we can see that
in our particulate diagrams
and keep in mind that these particulate
diagrams are not meant to represent the
entire solution just a small portion of
it so we can get an idea about what's
happening in the entire solution we can
think about the particulate diagram on
the left representing the initial
concentration of our acid h a
so there are five h a particles in
solution and also five water particles
since the reaction goes to completion
the h a particles are going to react
with the water particles to produce 5
hydronium h3o plus and 5 a minus
we can see that in our second
particulate diagram which represents the
equilibrium mixture and there are five
hydroniums present and also five a
minuses
we can write the equilibrium constant
expression for this reaction from the
balanced equation we look at our
products and say it'd be the
concentration of h3o plus and since
there's a coefficient of one it be the
concentration of h0 plus raised to the
first power times the concentration of a
minus also raised to the first power
divided by the concentration of h a
raised to the first power and pure water
is left out of the equilibrium constant
expression so that's equal to the
equilibrium constant k
and since this shows the ionization of
an acid we could call this this the ka
value the acid ionization constant or
the acid dissociation constant since the
equilibrium lies so far to the right for
a strong acid at equilibrium there's
going to be essentially all products and
very very little reactants that means
the ka value for a strong acid will be
much greater than one
now let's look at a weak acid we're
going to use the same general equation
here h a plus h2o yields h3o plus plus a
minus however if ha is a generic weak
acid we're going to include an
equilibrium arrow here the equilibrium
arrow needs to be included because weak
acids only partially ionize and we can
see that in the particulate diagrams
in the particulate diagram on the left
this is supposed to represent the
initial concentration of our weak acid
ha and there are five particles of h a
and five particles of water
since weak acids only partially ionize
let's say that only
one h a particle reacts with one water
molecule to produce one hydronium ion
and one a minus anion
so if one h a particle reacts with one
h2o particle that gives us one hydronium
h3o plus and one a minus
so out of the original five h a
particles only one of them ionized
leaving four h a particles still in
solution at equilibrium therefore h a
only partially ionized and is a weak
acid
the equilibrium constant expression for
a weak acid looks the same as it did for
our strong acid because we use the same
general equation however since a weak
acid only partially ionizes at
equilibrium there's going to be a small
amount of products and a large amount of
reactants therefore the ka value for a
weak acid will be less than one
let's look at some ka values for some
weak acids at 25 degrees celsius
hydrofluoric acid has a ka value of 6.3
times 10 to the negative fourth and
acetic acid has a ka value of 1.8 times
10 to the negative fifth since both of
these have ka values less than one
they're both considered to be weak acids
however the higher the ka value the
stronger the acid so out of these two
weak acids since hydrofluoric acid has
the higher ka value hydrofluoric acid is
the stronger acid of the two
now let's do a calculation using a weak
acid let's say we have a 0.10 molar
solution of benzoic acid which is a weak
acid and the ph of the solution is 2.60
at 25 degrees celsius our goal is to
calculate the ka value for benzoic acid
at 25 degrees celsius since we're given
the ph in the problem we can go ahead
and plug the ph of 2.60 into this
equation so 2.60 is equal to the
negative log of the concentration of
hydronium ions and to solve for the
concentration of hydronium ions first we
move the negative sign to the left which
gives us negative 2.60
is equal to log of the concentration of
hydronium ions and to get rid of the log
we take 10 to both sides
this gives us the concentration of
hydronium ions is equal to
2.5 times 10 to the negative third molar
it's also important to recognize this is
the equilibrium concentration of
hydronium ions
the next step is to write out the
equation showing benzoic acid reacting
with water so here's the chemical
formula for benzoic acid reacting with
water to form the hydronium ion
and the conjugate base to benzoic acid
which is the benzoate anion to help us
find the ka value for benzoic acid we're
going to use an ice table where i stands
for the initial concentration c is the
change in concentration and e is the
equilibrium concentration in our problem
we were told the initial concentration
of benzoic acid was 0.10 molar and if we
assume that benzoic acid hasn't reacted
yet the initial concentration of
hydronium ion would be zero and the
initial concentration of benzoate would
also be zero
we just calculated the equilibrium
concentration of hydronium ions which we
found to be 2.5 times 10 to the negative
third molar so we're going to go ahead
and put that under hydronium ion in for
the equilibrium concentration
so if the initial concentration of
hydronium ion was zero and the
equilibrium concentration is 2.5 times
10 to the negative third there was an
increase in 2.5 times 10 to the negative
third so we're going to write that under
hydronium for the change in the
concentration
and looking at the mole ratio of
hydronium ion to benzoate it's a one to
one mole ratio so if hydronium ion
increased by 2.5 times 10 to the
negative third so did the benzoate
anions i can go ahead right here plus
2.5 times 10 to the negative third which
means the equilibrium concentration of
benzoate anion would also be 2.5 times
10 to the negative third
since we saw an increase in the
concentration of hydronium ion and
benzoate that increase in the
concentration of the products came from
the ionization of our weak acid
in the balanced equation there's a 1 in
front of benzoic acid so if we write
plus 2.5 times 10 to the negative third
for hydronium and it's a one to one mole
ratio from hydronium at 2 benzoic acid
we would have to write minus 2.5 times
10 to the negative third since we lost
some of the benzoic acid when it ionized
therefore the equilibrium concentration
of benzoic acid would be
0.10 minus
2.5
times 10 to the negative third
since our goal is to calculate the ka
value for benzoic acid the next step is
to write out the equilibrium constant
expression which we get from the
balanced equation it would be the
concentration of hydronium ions times
the concentration of benzoate anions
divided by the concentration of benzoic
acid since these are equilibrium
concentrations we can get the
equilibrium concentrations from the ice
table and plug them into our equilibrium
constant expression so we can plug in
the equilibrium concentration for
hydronium ions we can plug in the
equilibrium concentration for
benzoate anions and we can plug in the
equilibrium concentration for benzoic
acid
here we have the equilibrium
concentrations plugged into the
equilibrium constant expression and when
we solve for ka we find that ka for
benzoic acid at 25 degrees celsius is
equal to 6.4 times 10 to the negative
fifth notice that ka is less than one
because benzoic acid is a weak acid
finally let's talk about the idea of
percent ionization
and to help us think about percent
ionization let's go back to our example
with a strong acid we started off with
five h a particles and all five of those
h a particles ionized to produce five
hydronium ions in solution and five a
minus anions in solution
therefore one hundred percent of our
acid ionized
so we can write 100 percent ionization
for this hypothetical strong acid h a
now let's go back to our weak acid for
our weak acid we started off with five h
a particles but only one of them ionized
to produce one h3o plus and one a minus
so four remain unionized at equilibrium
therefore one out of five ionized so the
percent ionization for this hypothetical
weak acid would be twenty percent
notice that the one particle of h a that
ionized made one hydronium ion
so we can also use the concentration of
hydronium ion at equilibrium to
calculate percent ionization
so the equation for percent ionization
is equal to the equilibrium
concentration of hydronium ions divided
by the initial concentration of the acid
h a
times 100 percent
so looking at our ice table for our
benzoic acid problem the equilibrium
concentration of hydronium ions was 2.5
times 10 to the negative third molar and
the initial concentration of our acid
was
0.10 molar so we can plug those into our
equation
so we plug in our concentrations and
molar cancels and we find for the final
answer the percent ionization of benzoic
acid is equal to 2.5
percent